Acreditamos que os computadores quânticos nos permitirão resolver alguns problemas mais rápido do que conseguimos com computadores clássicos sozinhos. Mas
entender como isso é possível é sutil. Hoje, no Qiskit na Sala de Aula, vamos tentar descobrir a fonte do poder da
computação quântica olhando para um dos primeiros
algoritmos. Bem-vindo ao Qiskit na Sala de Aula. Nesta série, vamos usar o Qiskit para explorar alguns conceitos fundamentais
comumente abordados em cursos relacionados à computação quântica. Cada vídeo é acompanhado por um módulo interativo
com link na descrição abaixo. Então, não deixa de conferir. Se você já ouviu falar muito sobre computadores quânticos, provavelmente ouviu
que eles podem usar fenômenos quânticos como superposição, entrelaçamento e interferência para resolver
problemas de formas que computadores clássicos não conseguem. Mas como exatamente essas características ajudam? Em 1985, David Deutsch foi o
primeiro a mostrar como isso poderia acontecer. Ele criou o que hoje é chamado de algoritmo de Deutsch, que consegue resolver um
problema de forma mais eficiente do que um algoritmo clássico conseguiria. Hoje, vamos dar uma olhada no algoritmo de Deutsch e
numa extensão posterior chamada algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa, e examinar como os aspectos unicamente quânticos dos qubits
podem ser usados em benefício do computador quântico. Depois, vamos executar esses algoritmos num computador quântico real com o Qiskit.
Existem outros algoritmos quânticos por aí que também mostram uma vantagem teórica sobre algoritmos clássicos conhecidos. E nem todos funcionam
com os mesmos princípios que veremos hoje. Portanto, o que aprenderemos hoje não explica em geral como um computador quântico
funciona, mas nos ajuda a começar a ver como os princípios da mecânica quântica podem ser combinados para
criar um computador quântico poderoso. Antes de mergulhar no algoritmo de Deutsch, vamos pensar primeiro em como os computadores quânticos
são diferentes dos computadores clássicos e em como isso pode nos dar uma vantagem na resolução de certos
problemas. Uma diferença é que os bits quânticos chamados qubits podem estar em estados de superposição. Em vez de se limitarem
ao estado zero ou ao estado um como um bit clássico, um qubit
pode estar num estado de superposição de zero e um. Escrevemos esse estado
assim, onde a e b são números complexos cujos quadrados somam um. E quanto mais
qubits, mais essa lacuna se amplia. Dois bits clássicos ainda podem estar em apenas um desses
quatro estados possíveis: 0 0, 1 1, 1 0 ou 1
1. Dois qubits podem estar numa superposição de todos os quatro desses estados classicamente permitidos, o que é
escrito assim. Em geral, um sistema clássico de n bits só pode estar em um único estado de 2 elevado a n combinações possíveis
de zeros e uns. Um sistema quântico de n qubits pode estar numa superposição de todos os 2 elevado a n desses
estados. O escalonamento é exponencial. Então, mesmo se tivéssemos apenas 10 qubits, eles
poderiam estar num estado de superposição de 2 elevado a 10, que é 1.024 combinações possíveis de zeros e
uns. O escalonamento exponencial do espaço de estados dos qubits é chamado de
paralelismo quântico e é parcialmente responsável pela vantagem dos computadores quânticos sobre os computadores clássicos. Mas um computador quântico
não é apenas um processador massivamente paralelo. Só porque os qubits num computador quântico podem estar numa
superposição de exponencialmente muitos estados não significa que temos acesso a todas as informações em cada um desses
estados. Como a medição colapsa o sistema para um estado ou outro, vamos
ver como isso se desenvolve num problema simples. Digamos que há alguma máquina à qual
podemos alimentar um único bit. Então ela vai aplicar alguma função ao bit e devolver outro bit único. A máquina
está dentro de uma caixa preta à qual não temos acesso. Tudo o que temos acesso é o bit
que alimentamos, x, e o bit que a caixa devolve: f(x).
Queremos descobrir qual é a função f que a máquina está aplicando.
Há quatro funções possíveis que levam um único bit a outro bit único.
Para descobrir qual é a função, podemos simplesmente alimentar um zero e ver se ela devolve um zero ou um um. Depois alimentar
um e fazer o mesmo. Cada um desses dois passos é chamado de consulta. Esta
é uma forma de comparar algoritmos clássicos e quânticos por meio do chamado modelo de consulta, onde comparamos o número
de consultas que cada algoritmo precisa fazer à caixa preta para resolver o problema. Então, nesse caso, o nosso
método clássico precisou consultar a caixa duas vezes para aprender a função. Vamos ver se conseguimos fazer melhor se tivermos um computador quântico
consultando a caixa preta. Em vez de primeiro alimentar um zero e depois um um, o
computador quântico pode alimentar a caixa com um qubit que está numa superposição de zero e
um. Então, na prática, estamos alimentando a caixa com ambas as entradas em uma única consulta. Então
isso significa que podemos aprender a função com apenas uma consulta?
Infelizmente, não é o caso. Vemos por que essa ideia falha quando a testamos num computador quântico. Vamos fazer um
circuit com dois qubits. O qubit zero, representado aqui por esta linha do topo, será o nosso estado de entrada X que alimentamos à
caixa preta, mostrada aqui pelo gate marrom com rótulo UF. O gate UF é
projetado para tomar o qubit zero como estado de entrada X e depois aplicar uma transformação no qubit um que leva
o estado zero para o estado f(x). Então, desde que o qubit 1 comece no estado
zero, a saída é x no qubit 0 e f(x) no qubit 1. Então, para encontrar f(x) para
tanto x=0 quanto x=1 simultaneamente, podemos tentar colocar o qubit 0 numa superposição de 0 e 1 antes de
alimentá-lo à caixa preta. Isso é feito com este gate Hadamard vermelho, que transforma o estado zero em 1/√2
(|0⟩ + |1⟩). Então, após o gate da caixa preta, devemos agora ter uma superposição de tanto
f(0) quanto f(1) no qubit 1. Quando medimos os dois qubits, esperamos
responder à pergunta: qual função está dentro da caixa preta? Vamos usar o Sampler primitivo do Qiskit para executar o
circuit e retornar o resultado. Podemos escolher o número de vezes que o circuit é executado, chamado de amostras, mudando esse
parâmetro chamado shots aqui.
Isso é equivalente ao número de consultas que fazemos à caixa preta. Vamos ver se apenas uma consulta vai
funcionar. Aqui está o resultado. Medimos o qubit 0 como zero. Então esse foi o
valor de entrada x, e o qubit 1 como 1, que foi o valor de saída f(x). Então agora
sabemos que f(0) = 1. Mas e quanto a f(1)? Aqui está o problema. Assim que
medimos o estado, as superposições colapsaram e conseguimos medir apenas uma parte da função com uma
única consulta. Isso não nos diz tudo o que precisamos saber para determinar qual é a função. Precisaríamos de uma
segunda consulta à caixa para isso. Então, mesmo que o princípio do paralelismo quântico nos permita simultaneamente
fazer a caixa preta avaliar f(0) e f(1), não temos acesso a ambas as
respostas. O paralelismo quântico sozinho não é suficiente. O algoritmo de Deutsch
mostra como podemos usar o paralelismo quântico de forma um pouco diferente para aprender sobre a função dentro da caixa preta. Não
seremos capazes de aprender exatamente o que é a função, mas poderemos aprender algo novo sobre ela com uma
única consulta que não conseguiríamos com um computador clássico. Vamos começar olhando uma tabela das quatro funções possíveis que
levam um único bit a outro bit único. Aqui você pode ver que duas das funções, f₁ e f₄, sempre
retornam um único valor independentemente do estado de entrada. Chamamos essas duas funções de
constantes. f₂ e f₃ retornarão zero ou um dependendo do
estado de x. Chamamos essas duas funções de balanceadas. O algoritmo de Deutsch
determina se a função é constante ou balanceada fazendo alguns ajustes inteligentes ao circuit que usamos
antes. Aqui está o circuit. Ele começa preparando o qubit 0 no estado 1/√2
(|0⟩ + |1⟩) com um gate Hadamard como antes, e o qubit 1 no estado 1/√2 (|0⟩ − |1⟩)
com um gate NOT seguido de um gate Hadamard.
Então o estado completo neste ponto é este, onde este é o estado do qubit 0 e
este é o estado do qubit 1. Preparar o qubit um dessa forma em vez de simplesmente
deixá-lo no estado zero permite que o algoritmo use o paralelismo quântico em combinação com interferência para aprender
sobre a função da caixa preta. Vamos ver como: quando os qubits são alimentados ao gate UF — o gate da caixa preta —, algumas coisas podem
acontecer. Se a função é constante, então a caixa preta realizará alguma operação no qubit um sozinho, independentemente
do estado de zero. Nesse caso, como o UF não toca o qubit zero nem
se importa com o seu estado, o segundo gate Hadamard aqui simplesmente desfaz o que
o primeiro gate Hadamard fez. E mediremos o qubit no estado zero. Vamos olhar a função balanceada f₂ como exemplo para ver
o que uf faz ao estado nesse caso. Quando x é zero, f(x) é zero, e quando x
é 1, f(x) é 1. Lembra o que te disse sobre o gate UF: ele toma o qubit 0
como estado de entrada x e gera f(x) no qubit 1. Assumindo que o qubit 1
começa no estado zero. Então, para essa função, o que o UF faz ao qubit 1 depende
do qubit 0. Se 0 for zero, o qubit 1 ficará no estado zero para obter f(x) = 0. Se o qubit 0 for 1, a caixa preta aplicará um gate NOT ao qubit 1 e colocará
no estado um. Então obtemos f(1) = 1. Isso é exatamente o que um gate CNOT, ou C-NOT, faz.
Um gate C-NOT pega dois qubits, um qubit de controle e um qubit alvo, e inverte o
estado do qubit alvo se o qubit de controle estiver no estado um. Mas não faz nada ao alvo se o controle
estiver no estado zero. Então o UF para f₂ é apenas um CNOT em Q0 e Q1. O gate
CNOT não fará nada ao primeiro termo, pois o qubit de controle está no estado zero. Mas no segundo termo, esse
zero vira um e esse um vira zero. E se fatorarmos um sinal de menos, veremos que o estado do qubit 1 está
inalterado. Mas esse termo adquiriu um sinal de menos. Então o estado do qubit 0 é
na verdade o que mudou. Ele passou de 0 + 1 para 0 −
1. Quando aplicamos o gate Hadamard final ao qubit 0, isso o transforma para o estado 1. Então, se a função na caixa preta
for f₂, mediremos 1 em vez de 0. Acontece que o gate UF para a outra função balanceada f₃ é o
mesmo gate CNOT seguido de um gate NOT no qubit 1. Esse gate NOT final não afeta o qubit zero. Então, quando a função
for balanceada, mediremos o qubit 0 no estado um no final do circuit. Agora, se você não acompanhou tudo isso,
tudo bem. Sugiro que analise por conta própria para ver como funciona. O ponto principal aqui é o que
aconteceu quando aplicamos o CNOT para as duas funções balanceadas. O qubit 0 foi usado apenas como qubit de controle para mudar
o estado do qubit 1. Intuitivamente, você pode pensar que o qubit 0 permaneceria inalterado. E, no entanto, de alguma forma, as nossas
operações no qubit um realmente mudaram o estado do qubit zero, alterando a fase relativa entre as duas partes de
sua superposição. Esse fenômeno é conhecido como mecanismo de kickback de fase, e é
muito contraintuitivo, como muitos fenômenos quânticos. De certa forma, você pode pensar no mecanismo de kickback de fase
como remar um barco: o ato de empurrar a água para trás na verdade te impulsiona para frente. Assim como as operações no
qubit 1 realmente mudam o qubit zero. Agora podemos executar o algoritmo de Deutsch no
Qiskit. Aqui podemos selecionar qual função colocar dentro da caixa preta, que escolhemos ser F₃. Aqui está o
diagrama de circuit do algoritmo e podemos executá-lo como antes com o primitivo Sampler. Vamos definir o número de
amostras como apenas um e ver o que medimos. Nesse caso, medimos um.
Então sabemos que a função era balanceada, o que é de fato o que esperávamos, já que a caixa preta continha a função f₃.
Então, com apenas uma única consulta, fomos capazes de diferenciar entre essas duas classes de funções.
Isso teria levado um algoritmo clássico duas consultas para determinar. Isso mostra uma modesta vantagem da
computação quântica sobre a computação clássica, mas não é muito impressionante. Apenas um versus dois. Mas o algoritmo de Deutsch
ainda é extremamente importante para a história da computação quântica porque forneceu a faísca que levou outros a
pensar em algoritmos quânticos maiores e mais sofisticados.
Isso inclui uma extensão com múltiplos qubits do algoritmo de Deutsch que demonstra uma vantagem quântica muito mais impressionante.
Essa extensão é chamada de algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa. Ela resolve um problema similar, mas nesse caso a função de caixa preta
que queremos aprender sobre recebe n bits como entrada e retorna um único bit. Assim
como antes, nos é prometido que a função é ou constante, ou seja, o bit de saída é sempre um ou sempre zero,
independentemente da sequência de bits de entrada, ou balanceada, ou seja, a saída é zero para
metade das sequências de bits de entrada e um para a outra metade. Há, claro, outras
funções que levam n bits a um único bit que não são nem constantes nem balanceadas. Mas nesse problema, nos é
prometido que nenhuma dessas funções está dentro da caixa preta. A função na caixa é garantida ser ou constante
ou balanceada. O circuit de Deutsch-Jozsa é similar ao algoritmo de Deutsch, mas com mais qubits. Aqui temos uma
implementação do algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa para aprender sobre uma função de três bits. Desta vez temos três qubits
para o estado de entrada em vez de apenas um. E depois temos esse último qubit para o estado de saída. Como antes,
de novo preparamos todos os qubits de entrada para estar no estado 0 + 1, e o qubit de saída
no estado 0 − 1. Então, embora a matemática seja um pouco mais complicada de seguir, o princípio
permanece o mesmo. Se a função é constante, ela não dependerá dos três qubits do topo. Então seus estados
voltarão a zero após os segundos gates Hadamard e a nossa medição produzirá uma sequência de três bits de todos os
zeros. Mas se a função for balanceada, então quando medirmos os qubits após os gates Hadamard, o mecanismo de kickback de fase
fará com que um ou mais desses bits seja um. Pode não ser tão fácil de ver desta vez, mas se você trabalhar
cada passo por conta própria, logo verá que deve ser o caso. Uma forma de verificar isso é tentar calcular a
probabilidade de medir todos os zeros com uma função balanceada. Você deve obter uma probabilidade de zero. Vamos executar o
algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa num computador quântico com o Qiskit. A etapa mais difícil é provavelmente criar a função de Deutsch-Jozsa,
que será a nossa caixa preta que consultamos aqui. Este código produz uma função de Deutsch-Jozsa aleatória que é
garantida ser ou balanceada ou constante. Depois, fazemos o nosso circuit de Deutsch-Jozsa inserindo a nossa caixa preta
aqui. De novo, executamos o circuit com o Sampler. E após a medição, olhamos para
os bits medidos para determinar se a função era balanceada ou constante.
Se forem todos zero, é constante. Mas se houver pelo menos um bit igual a 1 na sequência, então é balanceada. Nesse
caso, obtemos uma sequência de bits de 1, 1, 1.
Então sabemos que a função era balanceada. Espero ter te dado o teu primeiro vislumbre de como algoritmos quânticos
podem tirar vantagem de fenômenos quânticos interessantes e muitas vezes sutis para obter sua vantagem sobre os algoritmos clássicos.
Você provavelmente também percebeu como pode ser complicado criar algoritmos quânticos. Até o primeiríssimo
exigiu muita criatividade para alcançar apenas uma vitória modesta sobre os métodos clássicos. E desde esse primeiro algoritmo,
físicos e cientistas da computação continuaram a criar formas incrivelmente inventivas de usar a mecânica quântica
a seu favor, incluindo extensões e aplicações adicionais do algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa. Se você quiser
aprender sobre algumas delas, bem como experimentar os algoritmos de Deutsch e Deutsch-Jozsa por conta própria, acessa
o módulo com link na descrição para começar. Obrigado por assistir e até a próxima!